the n64 upside down looks like a koalas
face and here's a wall that changes
color when you pee on it
Vsauce Kevin here this is mind blow this
jetpack of sorts just set a record by
flying for seven straight minutes the
company claims their current model can
carry a 250 pound man for half an hour
at a max speed of 60 miles per hour but
if you prefer to sit down while you
travel try out this motorized easy chair
it's just a prototype so you can't buy
hello or this monster it's a 1,000 watt
subwoofer chair with two 16 inch
subwoofers and it can connect to iPods
or gaming consoles apparently some
people like to sit on recycled computer
parts with ethernet and ribbon woven
seats and case frame and others like to
sit on whoa the flexible love seat
incorporates an accordion like honeycomb
structure made from recycled paper and
wood it's kind of like a slinky for your
butt get ready for summer with the nerf
thunderstorm
it's a battery-powered super soaker so
you don't need to pump it and it has
interchangeable clips of water you could
stay inside all summer and just build a
giant Lego wall you'll need 270,000
Legos and probably a body guard with a
Lego AR C gun from district 9 or stay
inside for 30 years and build a
toothpick sculpture of San Francisco
there are eight paths for ping pong
balls to travel along as they tore this
incredibly intricate creation quick
challenge listen to this music box and
see if you recognize the song
[Music]
[Applause]
time's up
here's the mega answer
[Music]
this is a prototype of a screen that
follows your eye movements by using a
webcam with face tracking software the
idea is to make games like first-person
shooters
seem even more immersive and to make
kissing less immersive here's a kissing
transmission device basically you make
out with this strong looking thing and
it transmits the data to affect the
other strong looking thing and a guy
getting struck by lightning a Russian
figure skating couple won a silver medal
thanks to their plumber themed routine
[Music]
finally here's an absolutely epic
record-setting beatmania performance
we'll leave you with a riddle
[Music]
only one color but not one size stuck at
the bottom yet easily flies present in
Sun but not in rain doing no harm and
feeling no pain
what is it the genius of the week is
going to be a number scavenger hunt
here's how it works
I've hit in five clues each clue leads
to a number three clues are on this page
one clue is at facebook.com slash Vsauce
gaming and the final clue is in weirdos
of the month number two find all five
clues and up all the numbers and give us
your answer leave it in the comments
below and I'll give you a hint for the
clue and weirdos number two
Eurovision good luck and as always
thanks for watching
vsauce announcement um first things
first
we've got a brand new video on vsauce2
that's a little bit different it's a
conversation with myself and a group
called underbelly where they share with
me some creepy Pokemon facts they're
really knowledgeable I think you'll
enjoy it
speaking of you it's about time you got
rewarded more and so over the next few
months Vsauce is going to be expanding
ingenious of the week to include more
slots on our channel page right now
we've got two one is the genius of the
week that Kevin already mentioned but
the second one is a brand new title
called sauciest of the week this is for
someone who suggested something really
cool to Vsauce whether it was a private
message or on Facebook where there was
an online game or a cool image or
something to buy or just a hilarious
comment now for the first week I chose
so fuzzer because of all the cool things
he made with stuff that we recommend it
on Daum but here's the excellent part
each week the current winner picks next
week's winner so so fuzzer if you're out
there watching and you see something
over the next week that was suggested to
us or someone put something on Facebook
you think is cool let us know send us a
YouTube message and let us know who you
think should be the next week's winner
and then that winner will pick the week
after that so every winner gets to pass
the crown it should be pretty fun to see
what happens and hey guys as always
thanks for watching